the early reviews are in and while lots
of people had nothing but good things to
say about Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania a few critics were
considerably more harsh with the
Avengers established as Earth's Premier
superhero force and the Guardians of the
Galaxy patrolling the Stars a new hero
emerged in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in 2015. at long last Ant-Man Scott Lang
as portrayed by Paul Rudd made it to the
movies in his own self-titled film it
was a high story full of action laughs
and World building that would greatly
impact the MCU in the years to come wait
a minute did you just compliment me he
did didn't he kind of sounded like he
did in Sequel 2018 Ant-Man and the WASP
delivered more science-tinged hijinks
also letting audiences know where the
lead Heroes were during the events of
Avengers Infinity war after playing a
key role in Avengers end game helping
the titular team navigate the
microscopic Quantum realm and undo
thanos's Infinity War destruction
Ant-Man is coming back to the movie the
release of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is right around the corner
and it seems like a high-stakes Affair
to launch MCU phase 5. Ant-Man
Evangeline Lily's wasp and their family
are sucked into the quantum realm with
no method of Escape while trying to get
home they come face to face with the
formidable warlord Kang the Conqueror
played by Jonathan majors in the wake of
a few teasers and TV spots the first
reactions to Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania have hit the internet for
the most part things are looking good
for the long-awaited third installment
just after midnight struck on the east
coast of the U.S on February 7th 2023
social media was flooded with early
impressions of the movie and the
majority of Lucky viewers who got to see
it ahead of time are happy with what it
has to offer for example film critic
Matt coat praised it for its psychedelic
nature and consistency with the previous
two Ant-Man movies he also gave Jonathan
Majors credit for his first outing is
Kang a variant of he who remains from
Loki numerous other fans events also
gave Majors major kudos for his
performance this is the beginning and he
cannot be contained speaking of
performances geek Vibes Nation writes
Paul Rudd gives his most emotional
performance to Scott Lang in Ant-Man and
the WASP of quantumania as we see the
smallest Avenger take on his biggest
threat yet FICO kanagano of Cina Express
went as far as to call quantumania the
best entry in the Ant-Man Trilogy going
behind the scenes a bit critic Michael J
Lee shines the spotlight on Payne Reed's
directing and his Star Wars influence on
the film in their tweet Peyton Reed's
time as a director of the Mandalorian
episodes really shows not in just his
use of the volume LED Sound Stage
technology but the production and
character designs it's out of this world
even with the showering of love for most
Twitter critics so far there are also
more than a few people who've seen it
and walked away somewhat disappointed
Jeremy mathi of Slash film wrote Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania is a lot of
loud super-sized and constantly dialed
up to 11. too bad so little of it feels
new visually creative or uh just plain
interesting not even Jonathan Majors can
save this hollow repetitive exercise in
weird stuff happening another viewer who
got an early look was impressed with
Major's take on Kang but feels like
quantumania missed the mark as the start
of phase 5. credit Jordy pobleti found
it to be a middle of the road flick that
fails to be as entertaining as some of
its MCU contemporaries and critic
Courtney Howard notes that it struggles
to find its footing emotionally and in
terms of structure POC culture also
found Quantum media to be a mixed bag
writing Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
is a super weird movie and possibly the
most Star Wars of any Marvel film at
times the humor was overly silly and
took me out think opinions will vary
widely on Modoc as their tweet notes
this movie will serve as the
introduction of long time Marvel Comics
villain Modoc played by Corey Stoll
stall was also in 2015's Ant-Man as darn
cross AKA yellowjacket who seems to have
morphed into Modoc since moviegoers last
saw him Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
premieres on February 17 2023 and it
promises two post-credits scenes
[Music]
foreign